right clay travis is proof of that he's
one of the parents who spoke out to the
school board to their faces
he's a busy man he's the host of the
clay travis and buck sexton show he's
also the founder of outkick.com one of
the only websites covering sports and
politics that you would want to read he
joins us tonight clay thanks so much for
coming on so
i love the clip i know it was a much
longer uh speech that you gave and god
bless you for doing it um and it was
entirely fact-based
the reaction from the other people in
the room really struck me what is your
sense of where parents are
right now with what's happening in
schools
first tucker thanks for having me second
we're in the middle of what i think is a
grassroots mobilizing parent movement to
take back this country i really i know
that there are a lot of people out there
frustrated because the reaction that i
saw demonstrated that and where we are
in williamson county i think there are
countless people all over the country
who feel the same way that we do that we
have to go right to the root right
tucker you've got a television show i've
got a radio show we make good livings
doing our jobs but the most important
job we have is being a parent being a
mom being a dad and i think what
happened during covett is many parents
became aware of what their kids were
being taught look i'm a public school
kid tucker i went to nashville city
public schools k through 12. my kids two
of them are in public schools right now
i want for them to fit in in the society
and make the world a better place but it
has to be a fact-based reality and right
now it isn't and i'm excited about how
many parents are now rising up over a
thousand people tucker showed up at that
school board meeting here just outside
in nashville to combat the decisions
being made by the board i think that's
the only way i mean you have been
engaged in this and other people have
for the last year trying to reason with
the people in charge of the schools from
the biden administration to the teachers
unions to the school boards to the
teachers and say look this is poison you
can't create two you know tootsies and
hutus in america like you'll wreck the
country and they just won't listen i
mean i don't think there is another
option other than for parents to say no
more
that is the option tucker i'd encourage
everybody out there i'm saying this is a
mom-led revolution because if you look
at the crowd moms have had a lot put up
on them for the last 18 months they had
to bear the brunt of child care when we
had 15 days to stop the spread tucker
and they are just fed up with it and
they are leading this charge and that's
what i encourage everybody to do speak
out go to the grassroots confront your
school board members demand that they
use fact-based analysis and we will win
i'm telling you tucker we're going to
win i can see it it's going to grow and
spread and become even bigger than it
already is the anti-mass the anti-crt it
may well be the new tea party boy i hope
you that's the first hopeful thing i've
heard in a while clay travis i sure
appreciate your coming on tonight and
for doing that thank you
thank you tucker thank you very much hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else